donc selon la tradition horaire
de cette délégation je salue tout mais
tous mes collègues qui sont là et puis
je voulais vous dire
vraiment le réel plaisir qui est le
nôtre de cette séquence particulière
qui lustre et concrétise ce partenariat
que nous avons souhaité entre lunettes
et le Sénat moi je crois beaucoup à la
porosité des frontières si je puis dire
dans la mesure où l'action publique
nécessite quand je dis beaucoup
d'intelligence c'est à dire beaucoup de
volonté de travail
collaboratif et de compréhension entre
on va dire la fonction d'état ce qui
fabrique la loi comme nous et vous plus
on se connaît plus on s'apprécie mieux
on comprend le spectre de ceux avec qui
nous sommes amenés à dialoguer donc
c'est vraiment une très grande joie que
ce partenariat avec Lynette parce que
vous serez
aujourd'hui ou demain les cadres
supérieurs des collectivités
territoriales donc vous aurez peut-être
à subir nos œuvres en quelque sorte et
nous nous avons à prendre conscience de
l'univers qui est le vôtre il serait
juste une parenthèse hier au titre de la
commission des lois nous rendions un
rapport sur la métropole de Marseille et
nous nous voyons dans dans ce dans voilà
cette mission que nous avons faite la
nécessité de permettre aux élus locaux
de construire leur projet d'avancer et
que parfois il convient que l'État
encourage facilite accompagnent cette
marche cette marche territoriale et
combien vous les fonctionnaires vous
êtes au milieu de tout ça et donc le
sujet qui vous a été proposé est un
sujet qui porte sur des projets
collectifs associés à votre formation et
donc vous êtes allé à la rencontre de
nombreux territoires différents et
variés et je salue
quelques éminents représentants dont
notre ancien collègue
de cette donc cette idée adossée un
sujet attractif à savoir l'intégration
de la préoccupation environnementale
dans la conception des politiques des
collectivités a susciter votre intérêt
et je pense que la transition écologique
se fera sans aucun doute à partir d'une
volonté nationale affirmée mais elle ne
pourra se faire très concrètement que
par une action forte déterminée et
persévérante de nos de nos territoires
et donc vous permettez ainsi dérrigué on
va dire nos travaux de ce souci
d'opérationnalités c'est à dire entre la
pensée
et l'action il est nécessaire de croiser
les regards donc vous avez passé trois
mois au sein de la négation et je
remercie Marc LEDOR et toute son équipe
pour l'accueil chaleureux et attentive
qu'ils ont eu à votre égard et surtout
vous avez arpenter la France et pour
cette chambre qui est la chambre des
territoires
c'est une c'est une richesse que vous
avez en plus ce regard neuf et ce regard
d'étonnement qui nous aide parfois être
utilement disruptif et vous allez nous
présenter vos travaux donc il est
important que cette séquence soit la
plus interactive possible et vraiment je
suis heureuse que les collègues puissent
voilà la fois saluer votre travail mais
échanger avec vous et nous parlerons
d'approches budgétaire de la
participation des citoyens ce qui est un
enjeu majeur bien au-delà de la
transition écologique de l'évaluation
qui est vraiment pour nous ici à la
délégation mais
une obsession et tout cela sera
accompagné du témoignage d'un acteur de
terrain qui peut être un élu ou un
fonctionnaire
cette forme qui va donc privilégier le
débat ce qui va faire que je ne vais
guère m'attarder mais c'est un temps je
crois de préparation originale c'est sa
première fois que nous le faisons et
extrêmement
utile pour les travaux que nos collègues
Guy benaroche Laurent Burgoa et Pascal
Martin
vont entamer à partir du printemps
prochain merci beaucoup donc alors qui
sont les élus qui sont parmi nous ce
matin
ils sont en visio voilà très bien donc
je vous salue tous et au fur et à mesure
nous verrons sans doute vos visages
apparaître donc je crois que c'est Alban
qui fait une course introduction merci
Alban
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs mesdames
messieurs vous êtes donc en présence ce
matin des quatre membres accueillis par
le Sénat du projet collectif de
l'Institut national des études
territoriales lunettes qui est comme
vous l'avez dit l'organisme de formation
des futurs cadres supérieurs des
collectivités locales
débuter le 10 octobre dernier notre
mission s'achève aujourd'hui par ce
temps de restitution finale de nos
travaux l'objet de notre mission était
d'explorer l'intégration de la
préoccupation environnementale dans la
conception des politiques publiques des
collectivités territoriales nous sommes
intéressés aux bonnes pratiques mises en
oeuvre localement pour nourrir notre
propre réflexion et nous tenons à
adresser nos sincères remerciements
d'abord à vous madame la Présidente
ainsi qu'au service du Sénat pour la
qualité de votre accueil ainsi que pour
votre accompagnement tout au long de
cette mission
avant d'entrer plus avant dans l'exposé
luminaire de cette restitution nous
allons très brièvement nous présenter à
cette fin j'invite mes collègues à
engager ce tour de présentation
Audrey scofeni donc élève ingénieur en
chef qui est travaillé précédemment 18
ans collectivités territoriales dans
différentes strates et un détachement à
l'état et comme fil conducteur et ont
toujours travaillé dans la transition
écologique
Steve decam élève conservateur
territorial de bibliothèque
dernièrement directeur de bibliothèque
mes points d'entrée pratique dans la
transition écologique sont
l'accompagnement du patrimoine bâti dans
les enjeux de transition et puis bien
sûr la médiation de la transition
écologique pour rendre appétant les
citoyens dans la pratique de la
citoyenneté
Benjamin matchini une première partie
dédiée à l'international sur de
l'événementiel et puis un retour en
France en tant qu'ordinateur du
secrétariat français de l'UNESCO et
depuis une petite dizaine d'années au
service des territoires commune
communauté de communes et aujourd'hui
communauté d'agglomération sur les
thématiques marketing développement
local et attractivité
et pour ma part albaniele administrateur
j'ai reçu une formation académique
Sciences Po Paris à la Sorbonne King's
College de Londres je suis également une
très pénale en intégrer Lynette et j'ai
eu j'ai connu plusieurs expériences
professionnelles au sein de
l'administration centrale de l'État au
travers de différents stages et une
expérience de Chargée de mission au sein
du cabinet du maire de Lyon avant de
d'intégrer donc Lynette nous allons à
présent vous présenter les différents
objectifs qui ont été poursuivis par
notre mission d'une part nous avons
souhaité proposer une réflexion ancrée
dans des enjeux concrets pour les
collectivités locales d'autre part nous
avons tenu à élaborer une cartographie
des initiatives notables en matière de
transition environnementale ainsi qu'un
guide pratique susceptible d'intéresser
temps l'élu local que le cadre
d'administration territoriale
un objectif que nous avons
poursuivialité aussi de porter à votre
attention toute la diversité des
approches politiques et géographiques
des territoires en France sur ces sujets
et nos travaux se sont nourris de
différents rapports antérieurs nous ne
partons pas d'une page blanche ça nous
appuyer sur les travaux de France
stratégie notamment dans son rapport
publié en mai 2022 les travaux de votre
délégation notamment les rapports
d'information portant sur la démocratie
applicative et l'État territorial ont
également pu être des sources
d'inspiration pour nous enfin les
travaux de l'anct et de l'ADEME ont pu
enrichir notre réflexion collective
nous avons rencontré 36 collectivités
locales pour un total de près de 50
entretiens donc dans les deux mois et
demi de cette mission et nous avons mis
un point d'honneur à restituer le plus
fidèlement possible la complexité de
l'action publique locale de transition
et le locaux et cadran administratif
collectivités urbaines comme rurale de
strates communales intercommunale
départementale régional de sensibilité
politique multiple notre panel répond à
une exigence de représentation des
différentes traductions de la transition
écologique au niveau local et nous
tenons à cet égard à remercier mais se
laisser natures Burgoa benaroche et
Martin qui ont accepté de jouer le jeu
de la discussion avec nous dans le cadre
de notre mission
notre rapport retracera le grand nombre
de thèmes associés à la transition
environnementale eu égard au territoire
que nous avons abordé lors de nos
déplacements et entretiens mais ce matin
nous avons fait le choix de concentrer
les débats sur trois thèmes d'heures de
3 séquences de 30 minutes chacune
premièrement la vision budgétaire et
financière de la transition deuxièmement
la relation entre démocratie implicative
conceptique issu des travaux de votre
délégation madame la Présidente et
transition environnementale
troisièmement le rôle de l'évaluation
territoriale des actions de transition
sans plus attendre je cède à présent la
parole à Benjamin qui va vous présenter
notre premier champ d'exploration de la
matinée sur la thématique budget et
finance
nous avons souhaité introduire ces trois
tables rondes par une citation de Jean
Monnet
précisant que les hommes n'acceptent le
changement que dans la nécessité et ne
voit la nécessité que dans la crise
cette phrase est à moitié vraie et en
même temps à moitié fausse puisque nous
avons pu voir et constater toute
l'intelligence d'action qui était
développée dans les territoires et c'est
justement tout l'intérêt de ces trois
tables rondes de pouvoir illustrer cette
audace qui a pu être mise en avant par
ce tour de territoire
tout d'abord la cette première table
ronde tournera autour d'une question
est-ce que l'approche budgétaire
traditionnelle est devenu obsolète
à l'image des 36 collectivités que nous
avons rencontrées les territoires Jouars
majeurs dans la mise en œuvre de la
transition environnementale or elles
n'ont pas toujours les moyens pour agir
la conviction que nous avons pu
développer dans ces échanges c'est que
l'approche budgétaire traditionnelle
touche à ses limites face à l'ampleur
aujourd'hui nouvelle des enjeux élu et
DGS interrogé pose la question de
l'obsolescence de l'approche actuelle et
du besoin d'une vision nouvelle tout
d'abord quelques constats
premièrement les budgets des
collectivités sont morcelés par
direction et services sans un budget
transverse autour de la transition
environnementale
identifiée
les financements sont en silo cette
captation induit en miroir une gestion
budgétaire sectorielle et compartimentée
la budgétisation environnementale
est rare
sauf là où l'ingénierie le permet dans
les grandes strates métropoles
départements région aujourd'hui force
est de constater sur l'ensemble des
territoires qu'il n'existent pas à
l'heure actuelle de process financiers
valorisant
justement pour permettre de bonifier les
collectivités investissant dans la
transition environnementale
il y a aussi une absence d'anticipation
de manière globale face aux verdissement
des portefeuilles bancaires permettant à
court terme justement des prêts et
emprunts à taux bonifier et enfin de
manière générale
il est clair que la soutenabilité est
vécue comme punitive et au lieu d'être
vertueuse et bonifiée pour l'ensemble
des administrations et des collectivités
alors quelles sont les bonnes pratiques
budgétaires de terrain issus de ce Tour
de France des territoires vous
retrouverez dans notre rapport écrit
donc plusieurs situations dans
lesquelles les collectivités ont fait
preuve d'audace d'ambition au quotidien
pour financer leurs projets de
transition ce matin nous avons décidé de
n'en mettre que quatre en lumière
justement liées d'amants en aval au
process budgétaire
alors tout d'abord premier constat sur
ces bonnes pratiques
il existe justement une refonte des
budgets au profit de la création de
budget vert pour penser les
investissements donc dès leur création
avec le prisme de leur intox sur
l'environnement
la deuxième bonne pratique constatée
c'est la définition de critères
environnement environnementaux forts
dans le processus de commande et d'achat
publique pour favoriser et accompagner
les entreprises ayant elles aussi fait
le choix de cette dynamique
troisième bonne pratique désormais il
existe une véritable sensibilisation à
une formation des agents et notamment
des agents des directions finances qui
étaient jusqu'à présent considéré
simplement comme des personnes
ressources
et enfin quatrième bonne pratique la
présence dans les collectivités les
administrations de nouvelles compétences
comme celles d'économes de flux
justement pour permettre de générer de
nouvelles recettes par les économies
d'énergie ou grâce à de nouvelles formes
de ressources financières issues de la
protection de la production d'énergie
pourquoi vouloir déployer ces bonnes
pratiques à plus large échelle
l'objectif est justement de pouvoir
développer des boucles vertueuses autour
de la transition environnementale et de
leur territoire la crise énergétique
renforce encore plus aujourd'hui ce
besoin comme nous la mentionné un
directeur général des services
rencontrés je cite aujourd'hui dans les
collectivités nous sommes condamnés à
être intelligents
cette intelligence d'action nous avons
justement pu la voir à l'oeuvre sur le
territoire de 7 c'est pourquoi je passe
la parole à Monsieur le Maire de Sète
président de cette agglo-paul
Méditerranée et ancien sénateurs de
l'Hérault Monsieur François commaine il
va pouvoir illustrer ses propos autour
de la question budgétaire
environnementale concernant la formation
les agents les critères de performance
environnementale de la commande publique
ou des nouvelles compétences mobilisées
de son expérience de terrain et des
innovations mises en oeuvre dans sa
collectivité pendant 5 minutes puis une
parole libre pendant une vingtaine de
minutes monsieur comen merci si vous
permettez Monsieur le Maire cher
François chers collègues c'est un
plaisir de te retrouver je ne doute pas
cassette l'intelligence territoriale et
cultivé avec beaucoup
d'ardeurs et de volonté merci cher
François
Françoise merci de ton propos
introductif madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame et Messieurs les élèves de
Linette c'est un plaisir de participer à
cette réunion et effectivement je sais
pas si dans le midi on est très
intelligent mais on avait écouté quand
même les orientations que j'amenais
souhaitait impulser et nous avons
anticipé effectivement depuis 2013 2014
les
problématiques qui se présenteraient à
nous tôt ou tard étant donné l'évolution
des conditions climatiques sur notre
territoire alors effectivement en 2013
2014 nous avons lancé un contrat de
performance énergétique un partenariat
public privé et je vous cache pas
qu'actuellement le partenariat public
qui nous a amenés à faire une diminution
des consommations d'électricité de plus
de 57% et particulièrement bienvenue
parce que sinon nous aurions eu cette
année 2022 une augmentation des charges
d'électricité de plus de 1 million 4
uniquement pour la ville de Sète une
ville de 45000 habitants et nous avons
mis aussi tous les moyens à notre
disposition souvent innovant comme la
thalassothermiste c'est-à-dire on est au
bord de l'eau il y a des avantages
c'est-à-dire on va puiser dans la
Méditerranée les calories ou les
frigoris en fonction de la période de
l'année pour chauffer tout un quartier
qui est en cours de construction pour
chauffer la piscine c'est pour ça que
nous avons pas eu à fermer la piscine
parce que elle est chauffée grâce à la
thalassothermie de la même façon on a
des
sources d'énergie produite par l'unité
de valorisation énergétique qui permet
de traiter les ordures ménagères de
l'ensemble du territoire de
l'agglomération c'est plus de 125 000
habitants donc vous voyez il y a du
volume et on produit de la vapeur qui
nous permet de produire de l'électricité
et là par exemple on se trouve confronté
à des difficultés qui sont parfois
incompréhensibles lorsqu'on est un petit
élu local de province
quand on voit on fixe un projet de
renouvellement de la station de
valorisation énergétique avec une
revente de l'électricité un certain prix
de l'ordre de 105 euros et du jour au
lendemain l'état nous sort une
limitation du prix de vente à 60 euros
donc ça pose quand même des difficultés
pour pouvoir être innovants et en même
temps visionnaire sur l'avenir en
essayant de d'utiliser les moyens qui
sortent à nous pour faire des économies
d'énergie je parle pas de la de la
géothermie on est en train aussi de
développer je parle pas de la la taxe
sur les transports que nous avons
augmenté uniquement pourquoi réaliser
davantage de travaux sur la mobilité et
la mobilité douce favoriser les pistes
cyclables l'achat de vélo électrique et
j'en passe nous avons aussi développé
des navettes maritimes qui permettent
qui permettent de se déplacer dans un
environnement particulièrement
privilégié et je crois que il y a pas
une chose qui est vraiment
extraordinaire il faut avoir en
permanence à l'esprit cette volonté dans
tous les marchés que nous faisons dans
toutes les projets que nous réalisons
d'avoir
à l'esprit cette nécessité de protéger
notre environnement alors naturellement
pour cela il faut des hommes il faut des
hommes qui soient particulièrement
motivés et on a
par exemple créer un poste pour une
la transition écologique qui permet
d'avoir un agent qui se consacre qu'à
cela on a un agent qui est
particulièrement dédié à la recherche de
fonds européennes de fonds de
contractualisation on a recruté
conseiller
en énergie une économie partagée et je
parle pas des économies circulaires bien
évidemment qui sont notre lait motif au
quotidien à partir des budgets mais à
partir aussi de la pratique et on a
introduit des causes
environnementales dans les marchés
publics ce qui au début posait quelques
difficultés de mise en oeuvre mais avec
une volonté affirmée on y arrive quand
même
merci beaucoup monsieur comen on peut
passer peut-être à la deuxième partie de
cette table ronde justement sur un
échange libre et des questionnements
directement à Monsieur l'ancien sénateur
de l'Hérault
Monsieur Martin oui madame la Présidente
merci alors tout d'abord mais Guy le
fera sans aucun doute
remercier cette initiative originale
c'est c'est effectivement je crois une
première c'est ce que vous avez dit de
d'associer des élèves de Linette à une
réflexion particulièrement d'actualité
Laurent Burgoa s'est excusé il ne
pouvait pas être là ce matin mais nous
commencerons nos travaux tous les trois
en début d'année l'année prochaine
nous avons eu un échange avec vous il y
a il y a quelques semaines et en
regardant la carte de la métropole on a
bien noté que vous aviez pris en compte
nos demandes d'aller à la recherche
d'expérience sur l'ensemble du
territoire en milieu urbant miroral en à
la montagne à la mer et c'est très bien
Nancy non moi je voulais juste poser une
première question à Monsieur le Maire
alors qui est juste une question très
pratique mais vous avez créé un poste
dédié à la transition écologique
quel est son profil
de de ce poste et quels sont
véritablement ses missions elles doivent
être transversales je pense voilà une
première question
très
pratique et puis deuxième chose vous
nous avez parlé d'économie circulaire et
peut-être aussi connaître votre
politique dans le domaine des circuits
courts si ça a été mis en place
également à l'échelle de votre commune
et à celle de
cette agglo-paul merci
effectivement nous allons créer ce pôle
ce poste de
transition écologique parce que
effectivement c'est un poste qui est
particulièrement on transversant et la
grosse difficulté dans nos collectivités
c'est d'avoir des services qui ne se
parlent pas obligatoirement toujours qui
ont pas exactement la même vision c'est
pour ça qu'il faut avoir quelqu'un qui
soit un véritable
stimulateur de l'ensemble des des
services pour mettre en avant en
commence cette nécessité de d'appuyer
sur la tradition écologique alors je
crois que bien évidemment ce poste est
indispensable et il est particulièrement
apprécié je vous passe pas que beaucoup
de services de chef de service découvre
des opportunités qui s'offrent à eux
pour grâce à grâce à cette personne pour
le ce qui concerne excusez-moi madame
bellureau juste pour rebondir le profil
de la personne c'est quoi un ingénieur
un paysagiste enfin voilà juste votre
collaborateur
non non c'est pas un ingénieur c'est
quelqu'un qui était plutôt dans le
domaine de l'écologie et dans
l'aménagement du territoire pour vous
dire que ça part quand même d'une vision
particulièrement globale mais avec un
état d'esprit particulier
vers la transition écologique
elle est rattachée au DGS directement
Monsieur le Maire sur la deuxième
question concernant les les circuits
courts
pour les pour les circuits courts c'est
quelque chose qui est actuellement en
cours de développement et d'accélération
bien évidemment on privilégie toujours
les marchés sur notre territoire de cet
agglo-paul médias
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
justement c'est qu'on est parfois
confronté à des difficultés
réglementaires pour pouvoir faire
accepter certaines choses dans les
marchés qui sont qui sont passés je cite
toujours l'exemple d'une entreprise qui
avait entre
gagné un marché mais qui était situé à
75 ou 80 km pour une de la ville de Sète
par exemple pour une différence de prix
de 400 ou 450 euros si on prend le bilan
carbone les dépenses de d'énergie les
déplacements les risques de dans la
mobilité de cette entreprise j'aurais
préféré avoir quelqu'un qui coûte
peut-être pas 450 euros ou moins cher
mais 450 euros ou 4000 euros à la
rigueur plus chère mais qui soit sur le
territoire et là naturellement les
services des marchés n'avaient pas
apprécié ce genre de choses alors par
exemple l'économie circulaire l'exemple
le plus typique c'est
l'UVE la station de valorisation
énergétique qui produit de la vapeur
cette vapeur on la vend à une usine qui
est salée sur le port qui transforme des
oléagineux en
tourteau ou en
produit
qui se mélange à l'essence pour faire du
bio
biocarburant donc des ordures ménagères
on arrive à des biocarburant ensuite la
station d'épuration va nous permettre
d'avoir
des mots qui seront séchés par la vapeur
de cette usine valorisation
énergétique et ces boules une fois séché
on les met dans un méthaniseur qui va
produire du biométham et qui va nous
permettre de refaire tourner du terrine
pour produire de l'électricité là on est
vraiment dans la Grosse dans la grosse
économie circulaire après bien
évidemment je parle pas du
recyclage du tri sélectif sur les
ordures ménagères sur la sensibilisation
dans les écoles des
salariés des
bacs pour que le tri sélectif soit
appris et inculqué à nos jeunes enfants
dans les écoles on fait même des
composteurs dans les dans les écoles où
les enfants peuvent faire leur compost
pour assurer l'entretien de leur petit
potager qui est installé dans chaque
dans chaque école à Sète
merci merci Monsieur le Maire cher
François Guy benaroche merci madame la
Présidente bonjour Monsieur le Maire je
suis content que vous soyez là d'autant
plus que ça fait à peu près 50 ans que
je passe mes vacances à
Balaruc-les-Bains qui est mitoyenne de
Sète où j'ai de la famille et donc je
suis parfaitement ce qui se passe au
cours de autour de l'étang de Thau
Monsieur le Maire je vous remercie de
votre action d'ailleurs
outre cette digression familiale je me
permettrai trois réflexions ou trois
questions plutôt qui sont issus de ce
que vous vous venez de nous expliquer la
première est directement liée à la
présentation qui a été fait par les
par l'innettes et je vous remercie
d'ailleurs j'ai eu l'occasion de le
faire puis on voit tout à l'heure de
votre travail elle tient en fait à cette
façon de de créer au sein de vos
services
un poste et la question que je me posais
le budget et l'organisation de
l'organigramme du d'une commune ou d'une
collectivité est en liée aux politiques
et aux structuration des politiques qui
sont menées bien entendu il peut y avoir
des postes et des budgets ou en tout cas
des services créés en fonction
effectivement de votre propre
organisation
politique et donc ma question est-ce que
au niveau de vos adjoints au niveau de
l'organisation de votre équipe
municipale existe également une mission
une
pose d'adjoint transversal qui serait
celui en quelque sorte chargé d'assurer
auprès de tous les services ce lien
transversal dans les politiques qui sont
venaient donc dans les budgets qui vont
être appliqués et donc dans
l'organisation des services
je peux peut-être on va passer à cette
question je passerai aux deux autres
après si vous voulez bien de
[Musique]
j'ai deux vis présidentes qui sont
impliqués dans l'économie circulaire que
ce soit au niveau de l'aménagement du
territoire ou du traitement des des
ordures ménagères de l'ensemble de notre
territoire et je crois que effectivement
vous pouvez le constater
tout ça ça permet de maintenir quand
même des activités des activités qui
sont particulièrement à dynamiques sur
notre territoire et à protéger on est
dans un milieu fragile puisque vous
connaissez bien dans la rue que vous
savez les temps de taux les produits de
l'étang de taux je fais un peu les
publicités de notre territoire les
huîtres de Bouzigues et les boules et le
thermalisme de Balaruc-les-Bains sont
ont été parfois menacés quand même par
des problèmes pratiques de pollution de
pollution du
[Musique]
merci Guy la deuxième contraction si tu
peux faire
désagréable de faire la 2 et la 3 en
même temps encore merci qui donc la
deuxième question à portée en fait sur
le sujet proprement dit comptable et
budgétaire effectivement vous l'avez
bien expliqué avec ce marché public qui
pour 400 euros vous en fait perdre 4000
d'ailleurs j'ai entendu dans la
présentation que les économies n'étaient
plus des économies mais des recettes et
je vous en remercie ça c'est un point
important semble-t-il et donc ma
question est-ce que aujourd'hui il y a
certains d'orbes de frais existants qui
vous empêchent d'avancer et qui sont
liés justement à la non prise en compte
d'un certain nombre de budget ou
d'externalisation de budget qui pourrait
considérer des économies comme des
recettes et la dernière que je contracte
c'est comment arriver à une application
de vos fonctionnaires et une application
des citoyens de votre territoire sur ces
politiques que vous allez mener
merci cher François
limitation du prix de vente de
l'électricité à 60 euros ça c'est un
frein majeur quand même nous avions
tablé le financement de l'usine
valorisation sur la vente à 105 euros je
me semble-t-il je crois ou 104 euros
la grande majorité des
usines valorisation revendent à 130
euros si c'est limité à 60 euros ça fait
quand même la moitié des recettes mais
je crois que le problème il est il est
tout autre aussi et notamment quand on
parle des
des volontés de l'état de nous
encourager à utiliser
les friches industrielles les frichés
industriels on a des industriels et ou
des structures
[Musique]
à étatique comme par exemple je vois la
cité mais la SNCF qui est assises sur
des surfaces foncières particulièrement
importantes qui sont de véritables
friches et on a d'énormes difficultés
pour pouvoir arriver à avoir la maîtrise
de ce foncier
[Musique]
entre la mer les temps de Thau
le Lido
la loi littorale le massif de la
Gardiole on n'a pas beaucoup de fonciers
donc la moindre petite friches que nous
pouvons récupérer on le fait et
naturellement on dépollue et au
contraire on redonne la vie à ces hommes
là ça c'est un autre frein qui est qui
est permanent et puis après
de temps pour vous faire part de nos
difficultés que nous rencontrons au
quotidien mais effectivement il y a
souvent des contraintes administratives
réglementaires et qui nous empêche
d'avancer très vite
François donc pour conclure cette
première séquence trop courte j'en suis
consciente mais extrêmement intéressante
peut-être Benjamin
mot pour quelques éléments à
additionnels justement de plus d'un
point de vue de l'administration sur la
question du portage pour compléter ce
qu'a dit Monsieur comen on s'est rendu
compte que là où la transition
environnementale était la plus poussée
elle était avant tout incarnée incarnée
politiquement et incarner
administrativement il y a un véritable
apport comme l'a dit Monsieur comen
d'une ingénierie de projet sur de la
transition mais c'est avant tout un
binôme élu DGS qui porte puisqu'il faut
diffuser et percoler dans l'ensemble des
de l'administration et du territoire et
peut-être sur les freins deux éléments
additionnels on a pu voir que dans la
commande publique malgré la mise en
place de critères forts il y avait un
besoin d'accompagnement des entreprises
puis comme l'a dit Monsieur comen vous
pouvez travailler sur de la valorisation
locale mais si les entreprises ne sont
pas prêtes à mettre en avant un bilan
carbone c'est très compliqué de
favoriser le tissu local et c'est une
entreprise qui éloignée au niveau du
prix qui gagne le marché donc ça c'était
un véritable point et la question de la
bonification de ces collectivités quid
d'une DGF et d'une éco-conditionnalité
peut-être pour rendre ce cycle vertueux
alors qu'aujourd'hui on est plus sur du
volontarisme et de la vision de l'élu
qui peut travailler mais qui prend un
bras le corps tous ces sujets donc voilà
deux points complémentaires un petit peu
sur la question de la budgétisation
environnementale
coup pour cette séquence
pardon François je fabrique
bien mis le doigt là où il le fallait
avec cette nécessité d'accompagner les
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
répondre justement au vernissement de la
commande publique parce que les
entreprises elles sont peut-être pas
obligatoirement prêtes et le la loi doit
devrait laisser quand même le temps à
ces entrepreneurs de s'adapter à cette
nouvelle vision et
au verdissement de l'ensemble des
budgets avec des cotations aussi des
différentes dépenses qui devraient
pouvoir évoluer
merci cher François
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin de de
l'accueil que tu as réservé à nos
excellents stagiaires c'est exemplarité
de la capacité
des territoires et des collectivités à
innover avant juste peut-être de
remarques
en matière notamment de l'alimentation
et d'approvisionnement dans les cantines
on sait que l'approvisionnement circuit
court et parfait et parfois compliqué
quand vous avez à faire à des petits
producteurs il y a des expériences
extrêmement intéressantes de travail
entre les associations de mer
départemental et les Chambres
d'agriculture pour essayer de faire des
cahiers des charges qui facilitent les
appels d'offres à la fois pour les
collectivités mais aussi pour les
producteurs en sécurisant
l'approvisionnement et deuxièmement j'ai
entendu il y a pas très longtemps alors
pardonne-moi Guy je vais comment dire
agiter
il y a en Bretagne shington qui a été
créé par Jean-Yves Le Drian qui
s'appelle le breslab et très récemment
on a eu une intervention d'une
entreprise qui accompagne les
territoires sur un budget
on va dire quand j'ai intelligence
c'est-à-dire un budget qui n'est pas un
budget de comptable entre guillemets
mais qui est un budget thématisé et
aujourd'hui le budget il a une cohérence
on va dire
de développement durable c'est qu'à un
moment il a une dimension sociétale de
responsabilité
sociétale comme les entreprises mais
aussi une dimension environnementale
c'est-à-dire on est capable à un moment
avec le budget d'exprimer factuellement
l'engagement de la collectivité dans ce
domaine après avoir infusé et diffuser
parce que c'est bien le sujet d'un
portage politique et de l'accompagnement
qui peut être aussi par un technicien
merci en en tout cas et je suis sûre
qu'avec nos collègues au poursuivra
cette discussion qui est extrêmement
passionnante la mesure et le faire
savoir je crois que maintenant la
séquence est à Audrey pour la
participation citoyenne un autre gros
enjeu
merci madame la Présidente je vous
propose d'introduire la deuxième table
ronde qui porte sur la participation
citoyenne de la transition
environnementale
le rapport bernascogne de février 2022
mais en évidence une récession
démocratique à partir de trois constats
le progrès de l'Ascension la volatilité
accrue de l'électorat et la chute du
nombre d'adhérents aux partis politiques
de son côté la transition écologique
parce qu'elle bouleverse les modes de
vie et mobilisatrice parfois fédératrice
comme le monde le développement de
projets d'énergie citoyenne ou des
habitants se rassemblent vous produirez
ensemble de l'énergie à base de sauce
renouvelables parfois suscite
l'opposition telle que nous l'avons vécu
avec les gilets jaunes
les collectivités cherchent des nouveaux
modes d'expression se voulant
représentatif et constructif lors de nos
auditions ce questionnement est apparu
régulièrement il en ressort que
l'association du citoyen est
conditionnée à deux points premier point
une incarnation politique un élu qui
porte je cite sans incarnation pas de
transition mais également en deuxième
point un territoire qui répond les lunes
ne peut pas tout il a besoin d'avoir un
relais des relais sur le territoire
l'enjeu des collègues activités est donc
d'impliquer le citoyen au cœur des
politiques publiques de la transition
environnementale
cette implication citoyenne doit
dépasser la somme consultation la
démocratie implicative telle que définie
dans le rapport Gatel Houlgate
de votre délégation pose l'ambition
d'ancrer le citoyen dans la ville locale
de susciter son intérêt et son avis de
s'engager la démocratie implicative
apparaît comme condition de réussite des
mutations territoriales en embarquant
les populations
les démarches que nous avons observé
sont multiples parfois elle se limite à
la somme consultation obligatoire telle
qu'a tendue par exemple dans les plaques
plantes climat air énergies territoriaux
parfois aussi les collectivités
s'interrogent s'interrogent sur le
comment faire comment faire pour éviter
le greenwashing comment faire pour
éviter les confiscations de la parole
pour que la démocratie participative ne
soit pas la dictature de ceux qui ont du
temps
parmi les démarches identifiées les
démarches innovante que nous avons pu
voir lors de nos déplacements nous en
avons identifié 5 à Rouen
9700 personnes ont été accompagnées dans
le cadre d'ateliers de la cop21 entre
2018 et 2019 à Kingersheim les comités
citoyens
sont composés d'élus de techniciens et
d'habitants majoritaires en nombre
chaque projet de consultation qui est
présenté à ce comité et précédé par une
réunion publique avec l'intervention
d'inconférencier expert extérieur qui
porte sur la thématique qui sera traitée
à Angers la consultation citoyenne
numérique durant les périodes de
confinement à Mérignac la création d'un
nouveau métier ambassadeur de la
transition écologique à la rencontre des
citoyens sur la base des ambassadeurs
tri qui ont avaient été initiés dans les
années 2000
pour aller je cite pour aller chercher
ce que l'on ne voit jamais
et enfin la démarche de La Rochelle que
nous vous proposons aujourd'hui c'est
illustrer lors de nos rencontres comme
un modèle à la fois structuré et
laissant la place à l'expérimentation
ou l'initiative citoyenne marche avec la
responsabilité avec notamment un comité
citoyen
qui construit
et évalue la démarche La Rochelle
territoire zéro carbone un citoyen
siégeant en comité de pilotage et un
référent démocratie participative dans
l'organisation des services autant
d'actions qui concourent à réinventer
notre culture professionnelle monsieur
Gérard Blanchard conseiller municipal à
La Rochelle et universitaire
accompagnée de Madame Emilie Bou
directrice générale des services de
l'agglomération et de la ville service
mutualisé vont vous présenter vont vous
exposer les 10 nouveaux outils de
démocratie participative pour la
transition environnementale mise en
place à La Rochelle
merci merci beaucoup
bonjour C'est à vous merci d'être
là merci merci pour l'invitation bon
l'introduction a été posée donc
simplement vous préciser que à La
Rochelle nous avons en effet répondu à
un appel à un appel à projet il y a
quelques années des Investissements
d'Avenir c'était le Pia 3 et l'appel
approché s'appelait territoire
d'innovation l'objectif c'est de mettre
en place un grand projet qui mobilise
tous l'écosystème territorial quand je
dis l'écosystème c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
à peu près 130 acteurs du territoire qui
sont partis nous alors du monde du monde
de l'entreprise du monde associatif du
monde universitaire des services publics
également voilà et l'objectif c'est de
mettre en place un 70 actions exactement
pour essayer d'inscrire notre territoire
sur une trajectoire bas carbone avec
comme objectif d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2040 voilà donc
pour essayer d'organiser de faire
fonctionner correctement tous ces
acteurs du le territoire on a mis en
place un comité de pilotage donc le
comité de pilotage est constitué de cinq
acteurs majeurs du territoire à côté de
l'agglomération de La Rochelle qui est
porteur du projet et de la démarche
évidemment la ville de La Rochelle mais
il y a aussi l'université échelle
en tant qu'acteur du territoire le port
de commerce qui est un grand port
maritime français et puis une
association qui s'appelle l'atlantec qui
est une association une un qui organise
qui gère un parc technologique bas
carbone et donc l'ensemble du pilotage
est fait donc de manière plurie
pluriacteur on appuie notre travail sur
le regard des scientifiques on a on a un
conseil scientifique donc là il y a rien
d'original mais en tout cas très
diversifié depuis les sciences dures
jusqu'aux sciences humaines et sociales
et puis évidemment la question pour
laquelle vous nous sollicitez
aujourd'hui on a mis en place un comité
citoyen donc dès le départ on a souhaité
que les les citoyens au-delà des acteurs
du territoire qui sont aussi des relais
des cit soit présent et donc on a
constitué ce comité on l'a mis en place
il y a un petit peu plus d'un an
maintenant il est constitué de 36
citoyens alors évidemment il est à
parité
homme-femme on a souhaité qu'il soit
aussi représentatif d'un territoire
c'est-à-dire qu'on a regardé la
sociologie du territoire on a tenu
compte des classes d'âge parce que
aborder la question du changement
climatique on aborde pas tout à fait
pareil quand on a 60 ans ou qu'on a 20
ans on a fait en sorte aussi d'avoir une
bonne représentativité des catégories
socioprofessionnelles et puis un point
important notre territoire a une
dichotomie une dichotomie pardon très
forte entre les espaces ruraux et les
espaces urbains on invitera très
urbanisé et donc on a tenu compte aussi
des des zones d'habitation sur le
territoire on a lancé un appel à
candidature
grand public on va dire voilà on a
utilisé tous les supports de
communication on a eu
260 candidatures
avec suffisamment de monde dans les
différentes catégories qu'on avait
identifiées on a donc pu faire un tirage
au sort et c'est ainsi qu'on ne l'a
constitué on l'a mis en place et depuis
un an alors évidemment nous on
intervient pas directement à Glo pour
accompagner le comité citoyen dans
l'organisation du programme il était
prévu qu'une association alors ça
s'appelle Liffré c'est l'Institut de
Formation de recherche d'éducation à
l'environnement qui est aussi
spécialisée sur les questions de
participation citoyenne d'accompagnement
des citoyens qui va accompagner ce
comité en relation aussi avec nous voilà
donc le rôle de ce comité c'est de faire
de l'autoséine sur les questions qu'ils
jugent importante et sur lesquelles il a
envie de s'exprimer nous-mêmes on peut
saisir le comité citoyen sur un centre
de sujets notamment l'a fait récemment
avec deux axes qu'on a rajouté dans dans
notre projet La Rochelle 0 carbone sur
l'agroécologie et puis sur le tourisme
durable et puis surtout on a on a
proposé alors justement pour que
l'implication réelle des citoyens pas
simplement une force de proposition avec
beaucoup de frustration quand les
propositions sont pas reprises on leur a
proposé de de désigner l'une ou l'un
d'entre eux en l'occurrence c'est pour
être membre du comité de pilotage dire
que les citoyens participent à part
entière dans les discussions et dans la
prise de décision alors c'est assez
nouveau ça demande un apprentissage
réciproque entre les représentants des
des institutions des acteurs au sein de
ce comité de pilotage et aussi des
citoyens on a eu un premier retour
d'expérience là il y a un comité de
pilotage là on commence à mesurer
effectivement les attentes et les
retours des citoyens sur ces questions
alors évidemment alors ils sont
satisfaits de participer ça je pense
qu'il y a pas de discussion là-dessus
après évidemment il découvre et c'est
important pour nous il y a aussi un
apprentissage de la part des citoyens
qui découvrent que finalement la le
temps public la décision publique est
assez longue et qu'évidemment les
citoyens sont dans l'attente d'une
décision beaucoup plus rapide voilà donc
je pense que cette découverte réciproque
à mon avis est un point extrêmement
important parce qu'il nous amène aussi
effectivement à à modifier dans certains
cas notre façon de faire et puis aussi
alors faire passer des messages comme
quoi on peut pas comment dire dans la
décision publique il y a aussi une
temporalité qui faut qu'il faut
respecter voilà donc on a ça fait à peu
près 18 mois que le que le comité
citoyen est en place alors ça leur
demande du temps aussi puisque au cours
de la première année de fonctionnement
c'est 6 à 7 samedi dans l'année quand
même qu'il faut qu'il consacre donc
c'est du temps à donner c'est c'est du
bénévolat alors bien entendu tous les
frais occasionnés sont remboursés auprès
des citoyens pour les rendre pour les
rendre le plus disponibles possible
voilà voilà un petit peu en premier
témoignage ce que je peux vous dire sur
cette sur cette question du comité
citoyen et puis son action réelle et
concrète dans le pilotage du projet
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
extrêmement intéressante d'une opération
qui montre bien l'enjeu de l'implication
qui doit pas être artificielle et qui en
même temps je l'ai bien entendu et vous
l'avez dû vous l'avez dit Audrey vient
bousculer
le mode de travail
des collaborateurs des collectivités
c'est-à-dire un moment on peut avoir
l'impression d'une ingérence du citoyen
qui vient ralentir qui vient compliquer
voilà donc c'est aussi cet impact là que
vous mettez en évidence est extrêmement
intéressant et la la durée de
l'engagement la manière dont les choses
sont faites c'est-à-dire on n'est pas
non plus sur de la démocratie
participative artificielle quoi voilà on
est vraiment dans une sorte de
co-construction chacun à sa place
Monsieur Martin monsieur benaroche
pardon Jean-Michel Houlgate est-ce qu'on
peut donner
la priorité à quelqu'un qui porte avec
ardeur la démocratie
excusez-nous alors Jean-Michel
Pascal Martin Guy benaroche et je crois
qu'Olivier notre collègue Olivier Pacaud
de l'Oise était volontaire Jean-Michel
merci madame la Présidente merci d'abord
comment dirais-je aux élèves de Lynette
pour pour leur contribution notamment
sur sur systématique qui sont des
thématiques fondamentales merci à vous
donc monsieur Blanchard pour pour cette
initiative donc ma question elle est
très simple c'est à dire que vous avez
franchi deux étapes à travers ce comité
citoyen le premier bien évidemment c'est
de les associer à la réflexion vous
allez beaucoup plus loin maintenant dans
la prise de décision et j'ai envie de
vous poser la question est-ce que vous
vous envisagez sous une forme ou sous
une autre dans la mobilisation citoyenne
d'aller encore plus loin c'est à dire
dans la mise en oeuvre d'action ou les
citoyens vont s'approprier leur espace
leur environnement d'une certaine façon
et vont agir sur la transformation ça
s'est fait un moment donné à travers des
régies de quartiers ça s'est fait à
travers des initiatives qui mettent qui
sont prises notamment sur notamment en
milieu littoral sur les nettoyage des
plages et ainsi de suite ou les citoyens
donc sont acteurs d'une certaine façon
de la transformation est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous envisagez
alors
quand vous parlez
quand vous parlez acteur enfin je pense
qu'ils sont ils sont déjà acteurs
puisque ils ont la possibilité de nous
faire un certain nombre de suggestions
là là on est à l'échelle du pilotage du
du projet ensuite dès lors qu'il faut
rentrer dans l'action on a d'autres
dispositifs notamment on a créé aussi
dans le cadre de ce de ce projet La
Rochelle 0 carbone une coopérative
carbone au sein de laquelle justement il
y a des collectifs de citoyens qui font
un sérum de proposition par exemple des
projets de plantation d'arbres ou
d'autres types de dispositifs sur
lesquels on trouve des financements et
qui sont directement pilotés par des
citoyens
voilà enfin je sais pas si je réponds à
la question mais
si à partir du moment où vous parlez si
si l'outil et la coopérative citoyenne
qui permet à des personnes de
s'impliquer pour concrètement faire des
choses ça oui ça fait ça correspond à
cette question est-ce que vous incitez
justement à la création de ces
coopératives citoyennes ou de ces de ces
structures qui permettent justement
collectivement à des personnes de
s'impliquer
on incite évidemment mais on a mis un
certain nombre de dispositifs par
exemple il y a la coopérative carbone on
participe nous-mêmes à des à des
sociétés coopératives qui ont pour
objectif de mobiliser les citoyens
autour de projets de production
d'énergie renouvelable donc on a toute
une politique qui se met en place autour
de ça et qui mobilise justement les
citoyens en articulation d'ailleurs avec
ce qu'on fait dans La Rochelle
territoire 0 carbone alors ce que je
voudrais quand même préciser aussi deux
points supplémentaires que j'ai pas eu
le temps de développer dans dans la
courte présentation
d'une part on a aussi mis en place avec
université de La Rochelle une chaire
démocratie participative ça veut dire
que on a convoqué nos collègues
universitaires pour observer ce qui est
en train de se passer à travers ce
projet et nous faire des pistes
d'amélioration et d'évolution notamment
bien observer la relation qui est en
train de se nouer entre les citoyens qui
participent à la décision et les élus et
les acteurs du territoire aussi qui qui
sont porteurs de ces différentes actions
donc ça je pense que c'est un point
important et la deuxième chose c'est que
au-delà du projet La Rochelle territoire
0 carbone j'ai une collègue qui est
aussi vice-présidente à l'agglomération
de La Rochelle qui est en charge de la
démocratie participative et qui a
transformé notre conseil de
développement et une assemblée citoyenne
où là aussi c'est 82 citoyens qui sont
placés dans cette assemblée à côté du
conseil communautaire où il y a 92 83
élus également et où là cet instant sa
vocation avoir une action beaucoup plus
générale et pas simplement centrée sur
la transition énergétique donc tout ça
on est en train de l'expérimenter pour
ne rien vous cacher on a aussi besoin
maintenant de réarticuler un petit peu
le tout notamment bien réarticuler le
rôle de ce comité citoyen qui est centré
sur notre projet la transition
énergétique écologique avec le Conseil
de Développement d'ailleurs c'est une
question qui nous a été posée par les
membres du comité citoyen nous
interpelle directement parce que ils
sont bien accompagnés et puis aussi ils
développent aussi leur propre réflexion
il voit bien que dans la gouvernance
générale il y a des articulations qui
manquent il nous interpelle là-dessus et
ça nous amène à avec moi-même et avec
Émilie bood qui est avec moi-même donc
la directrice générale des services de
l'agglomération de voir comment on va
justement mieux articuler ces différents
dispositifs et donc ces différents
échelles d'intervention donc non
seulement ils sont acteurs mais en plus
par leurs questionnement il nous amène à
retravailler notre propre système de
gouvernance merci beaucoup je salue
Madame la Directrice Générale des
Services qui nous a rejoint alors mes
chers collègues voilà je vous invite
voilà donc je propose que Pascal Martin
et Guy bennaroche présente leur deux
questions il y a une chacun voilà et
ensuite Olivier merci merci Madame ma
présidente alors effectivement ça va
être rapide
moi j'aurais deux questions mais elles
sont très rapides la première s'adresse
à Audrey dans votre présentation vous
nous avez fait état d'expérience de
ville importante Angers Rouen et de
ville moyenne Mérignac La Rochelle en
d'autres termes est-ce que selon vous
cette politique de participation
citoyenne
serait plus difficile à mettre en place
en milieu rural première question et la
deuxième s'adresse à Monsieur Gérard
Blanchard on connaît dans bon nombre de
communes des conseillers municipaux qui
assez rapidement démissionne donc la
question est-ce que en 18 mois il y a eu
des défections de ces 30 citoyens qui
ont été tirés au sort parmi les 260
candidats là aussi en d'autres termes
pour mesurer un peu la motivation de de
ces personnes c'était court
dont vous avez parlé monsieur Blanchard
c'est celui en fait des projets mixtes
d'énergie citoyenne auxquelles vous
participez vous avez cité un exemple je
voulais savoir qui en fait dans ce cas
très particulier vous pouvez être à
l'initiative bien entendu mais des
initiatives arrivent souvent en fait de
collectif citoyens et en fait est-ce que
vous êtes souvent sollicité et ce qui
vous est arrivé effectivement dans ces
cas-là d'avoir des difficultés à mettre
en place ou les ou pour des raisons
réglementaires ou pour des raisons
politiques ou pour des raisons je ne
sais pas financière des projets de
coopération citoyens et autres les
citoyens et vous sur des productions
énergétiques en fait
machine à vrai je vous demande aussi si
vous pouvez avoir la gentillesse de
concentré peut-être
vous qui êtes en visio monsieur
Blanchard ou Madame la Directrice puis
après Audrey merci beaucoup et ensuite
on a Olivier
très bien voilà la réponse va être très
courte sur la première question oui on a
eu on a eu des défections on a eu
quelques quelques démissions quatre ou
cinq d'émissions de de citoyens qui au
bout d'un moment soit il s'aperçoivent
que ça demande beaucoup trop de temps et
d'implication soit pas nécessairement
tout à fait compris l'exercice alors
comme je vous l'ai dit on avait 260
candidatures quand on a pris que 30
citoyens vous devez savoir aussi que ça
a généré beaucoup de frustration parmi
ceux qui n'ont pas été pris donc voilà
on a on a on va dire une réserve de
citoyens qui qui prêtent à s'investir et
qui viennent on avait aussi pris soin au
moment de retenir les 30 personnes c'est
l'association qui nous accompagne avait
pris soin de de les contacter pour
s'assurer qu'ils avaient bien compris
l'exercice voilà mais au bout d'un an et
demi cette constaté oui qu'on a eu
quatre à cinq voilà d'émissions
premier point deuxième point sur la
question des énergies renouvelables et
dans une démarche un peu collective
c'est un vrai sujet c'est une vraie
difficulté notamment sur les projets
éoliens je vous cache pas
ce qui nous a amené avec une opposition
une résistance forte particules alors il
y a la question de l'éolien mais il y a
aussi la question que c'est souvent des
projets qui sont apportés par des
industriels qui vont s'implanter sur le
territoire selon une méthodologie
évidemment qui est pas nécessairement la
plus appropriée donc on a pris récemment
nous une une
comment dire une décision une motion au
sein de notre conseil
communautaire qui vise à décider de
prendre systématiquement la main la
maîtrise d'ouvrage sur des projets
d'énergie renouvelable notamment éolien
n'est pas seulement si photovoltaïque
d'élaborer un cahier des charges en
concertation avec les élus et les
citoyens en amont et ensuite de faire en
sorte que ces projets soient de manière
préférentielle des logiques de boucle
d'énergie partagée de manière à ce que
la création de richesse à partir de la
production d'énergie renouvelable soit
partagée y compris par les citoyens et
en l'occurrence dans le contexte actuel
l'idée c'est de leur fournir une énergie
produite localement et consommer
localement un niveau nettement moins
cher que ce qu'on trouve aujourd'hui
quand je dis moins cher c'est c'était
avant la crise on était pratiquement à
-20 - 25%, évidemment l'écart ne peut
que s'accroître puisqu'on est en
capacité aujourd'hui de produire une
énergie beaucoup moins cher localement
voilà pour essayer de répondre peut-être
que Émilie tu veux compléter sur un ou
deux points
par rapport à tout à l'heure c'est la
question qui a été posée sur sur
l'intégration des citoyens et
l'encouragement à leurs actions
individuelles juste évoquer le fait que
dans le cas du projet lrtzc on anime des
rencontres écosystèmes qui rassemble
plus de 200 personnes pour rendre
autonome des associations et faire des
rencontres pour des initiatives
citoyennes se
déploient sur le territoire en dehors de
l'agglomération en dehors de la ville
sans soutien forcément des collectivités
donc on encourage des rencontres et on
encourage la création de projets on a
aussi des appels à projets par ailleurs
qui peuvent soutenir on a la coopérative
carbone qui peut également soutenir dans
le cas d'une réduction carbone liée à
l'action mais les initiatives citoyennes
du territoire sont encouragés à se
lancer en dehors du projet alors sur la
production d'énergie bien sûr enfin le
contexte actuel
malheureusement de cette de cette
contrainte pour le projet on a des
grosse opportunités puisque ce qu'on
essayait de lancer depuis quelques
années là devient évident et l'aspect
financier
termine la conviction termine de
convaincre un certain nombre d'élus et
de territoires qui
freinait un peu le développement des EnR
coopératives merci merci beaucoup madame
donc Audrey pour compléter la réponse et
puis Olivier en rappelant que nous avons
une troisième séquence rapidement donc
nous avons vu plusieurs tailles de
collectivité de la commune de Luke 300
habitants aux régions à plusieurs
millions donc pour répondre c'est pas la
taille qui fait la
démocratie participative mais surtout
pourquoi on vous a présenté ces enclats
parce qu'il faisait système et il
rentrait en collision avec aussi les
services dans les communes plus petites
en fait
la démocratie se fait plus au pas de
porte on a vu par exemple la commune de
Tramayes qui en fait nous expliquer il
faisait des consultations citoyennes
mais même il faisait des visites avec
les véhicules personnels pour aller voir
des choses donc c'est surtout le fait de
votre cette présentation là c'est que ça
faisait système et ça rentrait des fois
aussi en interaction avec les services
comment les services intègrent
oui sénateur de l'Oise et je vois mon
ami Laurence saumon qui a les mêmes
problématiques que moi dans la Somme
avec
l'acceptabilité éolienne où on a des
territoires qui sont à 360 degrés
entouré d'éoliennes et pour rebondir sur
ce qu'a dit Guy benaroche et Gérard
Blanchard il y a en grande partie
répandue le citoyen il veut participer
quand il est écouté et il sait se
mobiliser il s'est vraiment se mobiliser
il crée des collectifs citoyens alors
souvent c'est en opposition en fait à
des projets qui lui ont été imposés et
alors il se livre donc ces collectifs
s'organisent vont en justice devant la
justice administrative c'est des
marathons c'est des parcours du
combattant et c'est vrai que ce qui se
fait à La Rochelle c'est formidable
c'est organisé mais quand la
spontanément le citoyen les citoyens se
bougent
qui sont très souvent
rejetés par la puissance publique et
notamment étatique et notamment
préfectoral
malgré le soutien des collectivités
concernées territorialement il y a un
vrai problème là alors
ma question n'est pas vraiment une
question c'est un constat mais on ne
peut pas d'un côté déplorer la récession
démocratique comme la très bien exposée
Audrey et lorsqu'elle s'exprime via des
collectifs citoyens lui dire circuler il
y a rien à voir
voilà alors c'est un espèce de coup de
gueule mais j'apprécie vraiment ce qui
se passe sur sur La Rochelle il faut
trouver le moyen de le décliner à plus
petit échelle et que quand le citoyen
veut s'exprimer qui puisse le faire plus
facilement que vient un espèce de gym
Cana judiciaire complètement
ahurissant et qui et qui aboutit
politiquement à une frustration qui peut
générer des choses
inquiétantes et Laurent c'est ce dont je
veux parler
pour cette expression je crois qu'elle
parle à chacun de nous alors il est vrai
que nous avons accès les choses sur
l'implication des collectivités
territoriales mais ce qui est mis en
avant aussi par Jean-Michel houlga dans
le rapport sur la démocratie applicative
c'est-à-dire la consultation ne peut pas
être un prétexte parce qu'elle génère
beaucoup de frustration et de colère
enfin moi je voudrais pas sortir du
sujet mais il n'empêche je connais un
exemple célèbre dans l'Ouest c'est Notre
Dame des Landes où on a fait un
référendum et on a fait le contraire de
ce que les gens ont demandé voilà c'est
assez quand même fabuleux et ça mille
bazar partout et on traîne encore le
bazar bref voilà alors même que j'étais
une opération qui est fait l'objet de
beaucoup de procédures très officielles
de consultation et de concertation
merci Olivier pour cette expression qui
voilà forte qui fait aussi partie de de
la façon dont les élus parlent
alors peut-être une réaction à nos amis
de de La Rochelle je vous avoue que je
suis en pleine confusion parce que je
sais que vous êtes de la recherche et
j'ai le bonheur de voir derrière vous
des affiches du golf du Morbihan et le
Morbihan est en bon département de
naissance je suis doublement intéressée
par votre propos merci de nous ouvrir
une fenêtre
nous nous sommes nous sommes
effectivement au Musée Maritime de La
Rochelle et donc il est pas surprenant
d'avoir ses affiches derrière nous bah
une réaction évidemment je partage quand
même complètement les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus je pense
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui il y a une
vraie réflexion à mener sur l'action
publique territoriale
pour travailler évidemment avec
l'ensemble des élus et avec les citoyens
nous on essaye de reconstruire une
démarche ici localement notamment par
rapport aux énergies renouvelables parce
que c'est le sujet qui a été évoqué ici
et le rôle des citoyens est fondamental
et nous on essaye de l'appuyer sur
plusieurs choses premièrement c'est la
notion de planification de l'action
publique là on parle de transition
énergétique on essaye justement de
planifier le déploiement de dispositifs
d'énergie renouvelables ça veut dire
qu'on va discuter maintenant avec les
citoyens donc c'est le deuxième point la
participation la concertation la
discussion qui permet d'élaborer des
cahiers des charges et puis enfin le
troisième point qui est important c'est
la notion de partage parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien non
seulement il y a effectivement il y a
une crise énergétique mais dans la
logique de créer de la valeur puisque
c'est ce qu'on fait en mettant en place
des dispositifs d'énergie renouvelables
comment partage-t-on la valeur et à
partir du moment on prévient alors là on
n'est pas simplement dans la
participation citoyenne à la gouvernance
ou même aux financement c'est il y a de
la richesse qui est créée localement et
comment on la partage et bien tout
simplement en permettant aux citoyens
d'avoir une électricité moins chère et
on peut on a aujourd'hui les les modèles
technologiques et juridiques et
économiques qui permettent de le faire
et c'est dans cette logique qu'on
s'engage là je pense que là on crée les
conditions pour une vraie discussion une
vraie construction de l'aménagement du
territoire avec les citoyens
et merci beaucoup
pour l'accueil que vous avez réservé
[Musique]
assez brillant aux élèves de Lynette qui
vraiment je crois que nous apporte
beaucoup et merci de votre démarche
merci de votre témoignage et je suis sûr
que les collègues Laurent Burgo à Guy
benaro je sais Pascal Martin qui vont
maintenant devoir travailler
seront sûrement amené
mais ils ont à fond assez exceptionnel
merci merci beaucoup madame merci
Monsieur de voilà d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin merci beaucoup donc il nous
avons une troisième séquence qui est
extrêmement importante avant
d'accueillir François Sauvadet donc le
président de l'ADEF qui est l'évaluation
alors
c'est Steve qui va nous en parler
l'évaluation c'est vraiment alors une
carence une
française assez générale c'est on a des
idées de génie on pense être génial dans
le diagnostic et dans la solution enfin
nous Sénat on pense cette voilà de cet
ordre là donc on y va joyeusement et on
se rend compte qu'en fait ça marche pas
forcément vraiment et quand tout cas la
garantie de l'efficacité de l'action
publique c'est nécessite des études
d'impact en amont elle doit faire
l'objet d'expérimentation c'est un sujet
mais surtout d'évaluation et de et de
correction et aujourd'hui je crois que
la confiance de nos concitoyens que nous
recherchons parfois une grande tristesse
et désespérance elle peut être
retenifiée par l'évaluation qui montre
un moment l'efficacité de l'action
publique donc chers Steve c'est vous qui
nous parlez de ce méga sujet de
l'évaluation
merci madame la Présidente
l'attente des objectifs nationaux
nécessite la participation active des
collectivités territoriales de toute
nature y compris rurales l'évaluation
des politiques locales par des
indicateurs et le seul moyen d'objectifs
et d'évaluer l'état d'avancée des
politiques locales vis-à-vis de ces
objectifs nationaux
lors de notre travaux nous avons
constaté que certaines modalités
d'évaluation peuvent être un frein à la
fabrique de la transition quelques
points d'abord la multitude et la
complexité des indicateurs exigés en
amont des subventions sont dissuasifs
notamment pour les territoires les plus
ruraux un maire nous témoignait
l'impossibilité de déposer des petits
dossiers auprès des services de l'État
parce que je cite 14 pages pour 1500
euros les petites communes n'y vont pas
donc l'évaluation en amont est souvent
subite et contrainte par les demandes de
financement ensuite l'évaluation se fait
seulement par des indicateurs
quantitatifs or l'accès à la donnée et
son traitement sont difficiles coûteux
chronophage pour les collectivités les
prestations externalisées sont chères
par exemple pour l'alimentation des
critères renseignés dans les pcaet
et justement dans les pcaet et dans les
demandes de financement la nature des
indicateurs est imposée mais
l'évaluation est auto-réalisée par les
collectivités ce qui pose tout de même
question comment ne pas être jugé parti
sans alourdir davantage l'évaluation
et enfin les collectivités qui se sont
appropriées le principe d'évaluation en
font une politique transversale de
formation des agents de sens de l'action
voire de démocratie applicative et de
médiation culturelle
vis-à-vis de ces constats des besoins
s'expriment comme celui de définir des
indicateurs d'évaluation normés
nationalement et facile à suivre
en somme nous constatons que les
collectivités qui ont le plus avancé
dans la transition environnementale sont
celles dont les sujets de transition
s'intègrent dans les politiques
sectorielles économiques sociales
sanitaire et de démocratie implicative
évoquées précédemment
autrement dit c'est une politique
sectorielle inspirée par les enjeux de
transition environnementale qui permet
de progresser vis-à-vis des grands
objectifs nationaux par exemple vire
Normandie fait de la politique de
développement économique local avec
l'implantation d'industrie locale
l'occasion de la réduction significative
du bilan carbone des produits
manufacturés
ou Grigny et shirolles de manière
différenciée qui font d'un projet de
géothermie l'occasion de la maîtrise
d'une tarification sociale de l'énergie
nous faisons le choix aujourd'hui de
présenter deux leviers qui encouragent
les collectivités à s'engager dans la
transition d'abord les indicateurs
économiques qui ont vocation à évaluer
dans quelle mesure les projets de
transition évite de la dépense par
exemple la ville de Malaunay de 6500
habitants au nord de Rouen dont le DGS
Laurent fucien intervient dans un
instant a développé des indicateurs
économiques et le principe de dépense
sur le modèle des nougawatts il s'agit
d'évaluer le coût de l'inaction et les
bénéfices de l'action et il vous
présentera un graphique très parlant à
ce sujet
et ensuite les indicateurs qualitatifs
aujourd'hui la majorité des indicateurs
sont quantitatifs les chiffres
évidemment sont indispensables pour
apprécier l'objectivité du diagnostic
cependant la création d'indicateurs
qualitatifs aurait vocation à apprécier
la dimension socio-économique de la
transition et à produire de la
transversalité dans les politiques
publiques monsieur fussien va vous
expliquer son approche en ingénierie
systémique donc Monsieur Laurent fussien
je vous remercie d'intervenir vous êtes
DGS de la ville de Malaunay depuis 16
ans et je vous laisse la parole pour 5
minutes
merci bonjour madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs je vais rentrer
dans le vif du sujet alors les
indicateurs et l'évaluation doivent je
vais dire une banalité refléter les
objectifs de la politique publique
poursuivi en mesurer les impacts les
écarts et valider ou corriger l'action
publique c'est une évidence mais les
coeur de notre approche du sujet à
Malaunay je fais un rapide rappel
historique pour expliquer notre démarche
en 2007 l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie met en évidence les risques de
déplétion pétrolière et son impact sur
le ranghérissement des coûts de
l'énergie et annonce implique de toutes
les énergies pour les années 2020
l'entrée par les coûts d'énergie tient à
malhonnêtet à la prise de conscience dès
2006 et au regard de des annonces et
scénarios prospectives de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie on
identifie une forte vulnérabilité de la
commune son patrimoine mais aussi des
habitants à cette inexorable montée des
coûts d'énergie les bâtiments méritent
de Lourdes rénovation faute d'un
entretien suffisant ou en raison d'une
conception trop peu regardante de la
performance thermique
depuis 2012 la commune de Malaunay a
lancé un plan pureuré annuel de
rénovation énergétique de son patrimoine
sur les 17500 m² de ce patrimoine un
plan très ambitieux et un investissement
financier très important et nous avons
fait le calcul en 2006 de la facture
énergétique qui était à cette période de
275.000 euros comprenant les coûts en
matière de carburant de chaleur et
d'électricité nous avons réalisé toutes
ces actions de sobriété d'efficacité ces
investissements c'est près de 300
actions qui ont été menées et pas
seulement sur les enjeux énergétiques et
climatiques ce qui nous autorise
aujourd'hui à dire que nous portons une
transition à visée systémique et donc
entre l'année 2006 et l'année 2021 la
facture réelle en euros de la ville est
passé de 275 000 euros à 253000 euros
nous avons réalisé sur cette même
période une courbe que nous avons
appelée la courbe sans action c'est à
dire une courbe tenant compte des
variations des coûts des énergies
appliquées de manière plus ou moins
linéaire le carburant le gaz électricité
nous sommes arrivés à une courbe qui
passe donc de 275000 euros à un montant
de plus de 565000 euros en 2021
c'est le montant 575000 565 000 euros
pardon que nous aurions dû à quitter
auprès des fournisseurs d'énergie ou des
prestataires de fournitures de chaleur
et ce delta de plus de 312000 euros
c'est ce que nous appelons le coût de
l'inaction
c'est ce que nous avons finalement
économiser en 2021 et cet écart ne fait
qu'augmenter
puisque l'énergie continue à augmenter
si la commune n'échappe pas comme
beaucoup d'autres tensions actuelles sur
les marchés de l'énergie elle a vu sa
facture augmentée considérablement nous
sommes beaucoup moins touchés puisque
nous avons réalisé 45% des économies
d'énergie que nos toitures solaires en
autoconsommation couvrent plus de 30% de
nos besoins en électricité que nos trois
chaufferies biomasse installées
fournissent 60% 65% de nos besoins de
chaleur et que 90% des kilomètres
parcourus par notre flotte de 15
véhicules sont au GNV ou à l'électricité
il n'y a pas si longtemps pour beaucoup
de territoires la transition écologique
était vu sous l'angle de la contrainte
en temps en argent et consacrer
ou bien nombreux sont les territoires
qui considéraient que ces sujets étaient
seulement l'affaire des grosses
collectivités des centres communalités
des experts des régions des grandes
entreprises de l'État sur les enjeux de
transition énergétique et écologique
nous avons cherché à Malaunay et dans
d'autres territoires à transformer ces
contraintes et nos vulnérabilité en
opportunité et les charges en bénéfice
multiple et les investissements en
économie future et nous pensons avoir
fait la démonstration que finalement ce
qui coûte cher c'est surtout de ne rien
faire alors on a on a joué avec le terme
de dépense entendu comme ces dépenses
futures que l'on évite en faisant un
petit clin d'oeil au terme de Negawatt
et ça nous permet de faire apparaître
une nouvelle comptabilité celle du long
terme
au-delà de la valeur économique nous
mettons en avant les autres bénéfices de
l'action c'est le pendant de cette
approche des bénéfices immatériels qui
comportent aussi une dimension
financière et nous appelons cela les
effets systémiques au sens de vertus de
l'action nombre de ses effets des
politiques publiques ne se prête pas
aisément il faut le dire à l'évaluation
quantitative ce qui nous fait dire au
sein de la fabrique des transitions que
nous avons
contribué à cofonder il y a quelques
années que ce qui compte vraiment ne se
comptent pas aisément mais peut se
raconter quelques exemples la révèle
innovation du patrimoine communal elle
redonne du temps dit à des bâtiments et
espaces publics dégradés ou mauvais état
et permet donc la mise en œuvre de
politique publique et d'objectifs
essentiels par exemple savoir nager pour
la piscine développer la créativité et
le lien social avec une école de musique
et des arts développer la pratique
sportive en déterminant majeur de la
santé psychologique et physiologique
développer le lien social
l'apprentissage du vivre ensemble et et
de la Coopération ça permet de créer de
la valeur à l'échelle locale et donc des
emplois de développer des compétences
favoriser l'autonomie face aux aléas et
aux tensions géopolitiques sur les coûts
d'approvisionnement en énergie et le
sujet est brûlant aujourd'hui ça
favorise le maintien du dissuasion
associatif local un facteur de lien
social de solidarité de résilience face
aux chocs d'engagement sociétal et
peut-être de lutte contre le recul de
l'esprit public en creux sommes-nous
capables de mesurer les coûts liés à
l'absence de ces services et de ses
équipements quel poids carbone si les
habitants sont obligés de se déplacer
dans une autre commune pour y accéder
combien coûte finalement l'absence de
tels équipements dans une commune en
termes de services sociaux
environnementaux éducatifs etc un autre
exemple qui peut paraître anecdotique
c'est une petite action mais elle ne
semble intéressante pour montrer les
boucles vertueuses que nous avons réussi
à mettre en place la lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire dans la
restauration collective
concrètement les enfants trient et vides
leur reste alimentaire et déchets de
plateau eux-mêmes ou plusieurs poubelles
et dépose la vaisselle dans des
conteneurs spécifiques cette action
permet de sensibiliser les enfants à cet
enjeu du gaspillage et de le réduire de
faire en optimisant les quantités
servies aux enfants des économies et
réinjecter dans la politique d'achat de
la commune en visant une meilleure
qualité des denrées Joël locale
notamment et ainsi en même temps de
réduire l'empreinte écologique du
service et augmenter les bénéfices en
matière de santé de qualité
nutritionnelle et de santé publique elle
permet d'améliorer l'ergonomie du
travail des agents de la ville qui
étaient chargés antérieurement du tri en
réduisant les risques
musculo-squelettiques et satisfait les
parents qui observent une contribution
plus importante de leurs enfants pour
débarrasser les trier à la maison elle
valorise cette initiative proposée par
les agents du service de restauration
lors des visites nombreuses à
malhonnêtes dans le cadre du
développement durable tour
laquelle reconnaissance stimule en
retour leur créativité et leur
engagement d'autres exemples comme la
végétalisation des cours d'école montre
ces boucles vertueuses au-delà de la
lutte contre les îlots de chaleur qui
favorisent une meilleure santé des
enfants de près qui préserve leur
ressources attentionnelles elle réduit
l'agressivité des enfants autant dire
que la réverbération du minéral n'a pas
le n'est pas la même que par rapport au
végétal elle préserve donc leur facultés
cognitives elle réduit les coûts
d'aménagement et d'entretien le Béthune
entre le bitume et le végétal il y a pas
photo comme on dit avec un bilan carbone
incomparable elle développe la
sensibilité et la connaissance la
curiosité par rapport à la nature et au
vivant leur implication dès le plus
jeune âge en les associant à la
conception ces oasis favorise la montée
la montée en capacité en maturité
coopérative des parties prenantes
engagées dans la conception toute la
communauté éducative et elle modifie le
rôle des personnes chargées de la
surveillance et de l'encadrement des
enfants
voilà des boucles vertueuses qui nous
semblent pertinentes et s'il fallait
terminer par des bénéfices plus globaux
qui sont stratégiques je peux vous
assurer que malhonnêt est devenu
attractive et accueillante pour des
investissements et des projets
exemplaires de toute nature sur le
logement d'abord c'est souvent ici que
les bailleurs publics et privés viennent
réaliser des opérations exemplaires sur
le plan environnemental énergétique mais
aussi sociétale par exemple la création
d'un quartier nourricier une première en
Normandie témoigne de cette capacité
d'innovation et de coopération qui est
très ancrée dans le territoire
malhonnet est devenu aussi un terrain
fertile aux initiatives citoyennes une
Association pour le Maintien d'une
Agriculture Paysanne s'est créée en
quelques semaines il y a maintenant cinq
ans un système d'échange local des
projets coopératifs et solidaires des
jardins partagés la création d'une
future communauté énergétique citoyenne
pour partager l'énergie en circuit court
et puis comme nous mettons en récit
cette dynamique la visibilité que donne
cette tra au travers des retours médias
locaux et nationaux donne un sentiment
de fierté aux habitants une fierté qui
est une vraie ressource pour les
mobiliser et qui permet de faire
connaître aussi auprès du territoire et
de l'ensemble des habitants les
initiatives que les citoyens et les
partis prenants portent voilà je vous
remercie de votre attention et j'aurai
plaisir à répondre à vos questions merci
beaucoup pour votre présence parmi nous
votre présentation de votre démarche qui
montre vraiment une autre taille de de
collectivité la capacité à décliner cet
engagement
quel que soit la taille de la
collectivité y a-t-il des questions mes
chers collègues monsieur benaroche juste
une une réflexion une question la
réflexion elle est très simple je
voulais vous féliciter je vous dis bravo
vous avez démontré expliqué ce qu'est
l'écologie pratique sur le terrain
appliqué qu'on réalisait un certain
nombre de villes et de villages français
depuis des années on connaît des
exemples il y a eu beaucoup de bouquins
qui sont sortis qui sont des
récapitulatifs d'exemples de ville et de
villages qui ont fait ce que vous avez
fait vous êtes peu nombreux à l'avoir
fait depuis longtemps et en tout cas là
où ça a été fait ça a montré que ça
fonctionnait et ça a permis aujourd'hui
en période de crise de montrer à quel
point les citoyens y compris
financièrement pouvaient retirer à
profit la deuxième chose c'est une
question vous êtes vous avez mis en
place des indicateurs qualitatifs là
aussi vous avez valeur d'exemple dans
notre pays nous demandant de pilote à la
mise en place d'indicateurs qualitatif
qui nous permettrait de remplacer le
sacro-saint PIB par tout un tas d'autres
indicateurs ça m'a fait l'objet de
projet de loi et proposition de loi
est-ce que vous pensez que ces
indicateurs qualitatifs ont fait leurs
preuves dans l'application des
politiques que vous venez
je vous en prie
on est sur on est sur des approches très
très transversales et il est évident que
sortir des indicateurs qui sont les
nôtres aujourd'hui pour mesurer la
création de valeur pour mesurer les
effets positifs
[Musique]
de l'action publique en général mais
aussi de l'implication des différents
acteurs sur un territoire sur ces enjeux
de transition et de transformation de de
nos pratiques et potentiellement de nos
modes de vie ont des effets qui sont
difficilement mesurables mais qui pour
autant sont essentiels
j'entends souvent parler de la question
de la rentabilité mais est-ce que toutes
les politiques publiques engagées sur
les questions éducatives sur les
questions de développement de la
pratique sportive qui ont des impacts
que nous savons extrêmement stratégiques
sur les questions de santé publique sur
la question d'une association est-ce que
nous sommes donc a pas de citer de dire
que ces projets sont rentables est-ce
qu'un gymnase est-ce qu'une piscine est
rentable elle apporte des services elle
contribue à faire société
il faudrait qu'on puisse avoir une
approche
peut-être plus qui permettent
d'apprécier la qualité la qualité de des
questions de des contributions
des parties prenantes la qualité de
coopération la qualité du bien vivre la
qualité
démocratique
dans un territoire ou bien au-delà d'un
territoire bref on attend nous de
pouvoir être évalué aussi et notamment
appuyer et soutenu sur la base d'un
certain nombre d'indicateurs qui ne sont
pas seulement des indicateurs mécaniques
et quantitatif même s'ils sont utiles
pour nous pour mesurer la pertinence
d'une trajectoire de de d'économie
d'énergie on a besoin de savoir combien
de kilowattheure en économise on essaie
de gérer le mieux possible les données
publiques et donc on a besoin de savoir
qu'ils économies on réalise donc ça ça
se traduit de manière très précise et
concrète et pour autant les effets en
termes de santé publique les effets
sociétaux sociaux économiques sont
difficiles à mesurer et pour autant ils
sont ils sont essentiels oui nous sommes
nous sommes en attente de dispositifs
qui nous permettent de valoriser les
effets et les impacts
qualitatif des politiques publiques
merci beaucoup monsieur c'est votre
intervention permet de boucler avec ce
qui a été dit par Benjamin c'est-à-dire
le fait que un budget n'est pas qu'une
affaire comptable et qu'il y a de la
valeur ajoutée en matière sociale et en
matière économique alors moi monsieur
j'aime le mot rentable dans son
acceptation initiale c'est-à-dire la
rentabilité c'est la notion un mot un
peu Dézé pour parler de la valeur
ajoutée mais qui pour moi n'est pas
économique ou lucrative c'est-à-dire il
y a une rentabilité sociale à un moment
voilà donc c'est un mot qui a un
caractère
horriblement capitaliste
mais si on lui rend sa pureté je voilà
je pense que ça peut être d'une merci en
tout cas vraiment monsieur je suis
désolé de devoir
comment dire mettre un terme à cette
partie de notre réunion parce que le
président des départements de France est
arrivé il patiente mais je ne voudrais
pas que l'impatience guette les
départements en tout cas merci beaucoup
et je suis sûr encore une fois comme je
l'ai dit à vos prédécesseurs que nos
collègues Guy benaroche Pascal Martin et
Laurent Burgoa qui vont porter nos
travaux
seront sûrement amenés à retravailler
avec vous et en tout cas à utiliser ce
que nous avons découvert grâce à nos
remarquables stagiaires dans nos travaux
merci merci beaucoup monsieur merci
vraiment merci peut-être souhaitez-vous
un mot de conclusion
sinon moi je vais le faire
mais on peut partager on peut on peut
bien évidemment vous renouveler
rapidement nos remerciements bien sûr
pour pour cette mission on espère bien
évidemment que nos travaux enrichiront
autant que possible le rapport
sénatorial du premier semestre 2023 vous
avez donc là un panel de collectivités
locales un terreau de réflexion qui nous
l'espérons se permettra des
prolongements de réflexion les plus
fructueux possible pour la suite merci
alors on va voir avec
on sent que vous inspirez beaucoup donc
on va voir avec Marc le dors si c'est
pour Noël ou le 31 décembre
voilà en tout cas au nom de la
délégation je veux vraiment saluer
l'excellence de votre travail
l'éclairage que vous nous apportez que
vous avez eu à coeur d'être exhaustive à
la fois dans les dans les thématiques
mais aussi assez exhaustive dans le
panel de collectivité
et puis
je crois que
vraiment
cette expérience pour nous d'accueil de
stagiaires encore une fois je remercie
vraiment Marc ledoy et toute l'équipe
voilà c'est une je trouve que c'est
d'une richesse d'un échange voilà donc
c'est une expérience fort heureuse sur
la porosité qualitative du Sénat donc
merci à vous et moi je mes chers
collègues que nous applaudissions très
chaleureusement
et merci à mes collègues d'avoir été là
ce matin parce que les emplois du temps
sont très croisés dans cette maison
vraiment merci merci beaucoup et nous
allons maintenant accueillir le
président des départements de France
Monsieur Sauvadet merci vraiment